The Shining has attracted an almost cult-like
collective of fans who long to discover its
secrets.
What follows are our favorite fan theories
we've gathered up from internet forums, fan
films and documentaries like Room 237, and
just putting the movie on repeat until we
start coming up with our own kooky headcanons.
Out of all the theories out there about the
true meaning of The Shining, one of the more
plausible ones is that the film is an allegorical
tale about the genocide of Native Americans
by white settlers.
The most overt hint occurs when Stuart Ullman,
a smiling white guy who dresses in red, white,
and blue, and has an American flag on his
desk, casually mentions that the Overlook
is literally built over dead Native Americans.
"The site is supposed to be located on an
Indian burial ground, and I believe they actually
had to repel a few Indian attacks as they
were building it."
Throughout the hotel are depictions of Native
Americans and Native American art motifs,
such as the enormous sand painting on the
wall of the Colorado Lounge.
Jack even uses the phrase "White Man's Burden,"
in a conversation with Lloyd, a reference
to a poem by Rudyard Kipling that valorizes
the colonization of natives by white imperialists,
Internet film scholar Kevin McLeod, who did
a commentary track for the home video release
of the documentary Room 237, also claims that
the film features a pair of hidden symbols
from another group of indigenous Americans,
the Maya.
He asserts that in the iconic bright yellow
film poster for The Shining, the extra wide
letter "T" in the title is actually a Mayan
symbol, and that a repeating pattern in the
carpet of the Gold Room, a cross within a
square, is actually the symbol for "yellow."
There are also a handful of strange but compelling
parallels between the film and the real life
founding of Point Pleasant, West Virginia.
This was a horrific, bloody event with countless
Native Americans casualties, but perhaps the
most famous Native person killed there was
Hokolesqua, also known as Chief Cornstalk.
In 1777, Hokolesqua was killed by a mob seeking
revenge for an attack that he'd had no part
of, and, of course, legend states that Hokolesqua's
final words were a curse on the land that
would leave it, quote, "paralyzed by the stain
of our blood."
"There are two things I know about white people:
They love Rachael Ray, and they are terrified
of curses."
This statement has clear parallels to the
famous wave of blood from the film, but believe
it or not, it's not the biggest link between
the battle of Point Pleasant and The Shining.
In 1909, the same year the fictional Overlook
Hotel was completed in the film, a real life
monument in Point Pleasant was struck by lightning,
and the same thing happened again on July
4, 1921.
As any true Shining fan knows, July 4, 1921,
is the date on the old photograph of Jack
from the final shot of the film.
Before we go any further, let's get one thing
straight.
The moon landing wasn't faked.
Mythbusters did a whole episode about it..
Go watch Hidden Figures.
Educate yourself.
However, there has been a conspiracy theory
circulating since before The Shining came
out that the Apollo 11 moon landing was faked,
and that Stanley Kubrick was the one hired
by the government to shoot it.
It would obviously be nearly impossible to
carry a secret like that without letting it
out somewhere, so could The Shining actually
be Kubrick's covert confession?
"I don't think that's true."
Well, no.
but let's run down the conspiracy's favorite
evidence.
There's Tang in the Overlook pantry, a product
popularized through its association with the
space program.
In one scene, Danny is wearing a handmade
sweater famously depicting Apollo 11 and the
Saturn V rocket.
Also, during the adaptation from the book
to the film, the most haunted room in the
hotel changed room numbers, from 217 to 237,
and according to Shining conspiracy theorists,
the distance to the moon is about 237,000
miles away.
In truth, it's more like 238,900 miles away
on average, but we didn't know this until
the late '60s.
Maybe Kubrick was looking at an old textbook
with out of date information when he and NASA
were trying to fool the entire world by faking
the most documented news story of all time.
This could all be intentional, though.
By 1980, Kubrick was most likely aware of
the conspiracy theory, since it sprung up
after he directed 2001: A Space Odyssey in
1968, and he also knew how closely people
analyzed his films for hidden meanings.
Maybe he decided to just mess with them a
little for fun.
We all know what happens when it's all work
and no play.
One of the most subtly haunting elements of
the Overlook Hotel is that its layout constantly
seems to be shifting.
The bright exterior window in Ullman's office
is completely nonsensical, because his office
is in the middle of the building.
And during a conversation between Wendy and
Jack in the Colorado Lounge, a chair in the
background keeps appearing and disappearing
again between shots.
And when Hallorann is giving a tour to Wendy
and Danny, they step into one giant freezer,
but then exit from a different freezer across
the room.
Kubrick was a notoriously meticulous filmmaker,
so it seems unlikely that these strange occurrences
are just mistakes.
What else might they signify?
Maybe the Overlook isn't actually the Overlook
at all.
Instead, it's Hell, where Jack must continually
repeat the last winter of his life forever.
It's not that big of a stretch, as we already
know the hotel has at least one other imprisoned,
killer ghost in the form of Grady, who sometimes
doesn't seem to remember killing his family.
With this reading, many of the film's more
puzzling lines suddenly become meaningful,
like Jack having an odd familiarity with the
Overlook before he even arrives.
"When I came up here for my interview, it
was as though I'd been here before."
Later, Grady tells him that he's always been
the caretaker, and maybe that eternity at
the hotel is his reward for the sins of his
life.
Remember, unlike Wendy and Danny, Jack is
only ever seen in the Overlook or on the road
that leads up to it.
Whenever you're watching The Shining, Jack
is always the caretaker.
There are a lot of continuity errors and geographical
oddities in The Shining, but maybe that's
because Jack and his family are hallucinating
throughout their stay at the Overlook.
In fact, maybe they're the subject of a government-run
science experiment.
According to this theory, Jack's employment
at the Overlook is a front so that the US
government can test out mind control techniques
on isolated test subjects, and all the supernatural
visions the Torrances experience are actually
the results of these experiments.
It's a fun theory, but there's not much evidence
to back it up, apart from a single incongruous
poster in the game room.
It's an image of a skier above the word "Monarch,"
which is the first time Danny sees the Grady
girls in the hotel.
However, during Jack's interview, Ullman claims
that there's no skiing in the area, so why
would they advertise it in the game room?
And what is "Monarch?"
Well, it's actually Monarch Mountain, a ski
resort that's been open in Colorado since
1939, but according to conspiracy theorists,
Monarch was the name of a real-world CIA project
that attempted to discover the secrets of
mind control.
In this reading of the film, the character
Bill Watson, who seems like Stuart Ullman's
assistant, is actually the brains of the operation,
a high-ranking government agent.
Notice that Watson is called into Ullman's
office when Jack arrives, and yet he doesn't
get a job title, and he doesn't ask Jack any
questions.
In fact, he doesn't have any dialogue at all
other than a blunt "hi" later on.
He just sits there, watching as Ullman tells
Jack about Grady and the Overlook's creepy
history, planting those ideas in Jack's head.
Later, when Ullman tells Watson to transport
some luggage, Watson almost seems annoyed,
like he's not used to taking orders.
And when Ullman gives Jack a tour, Watson
trails behind, watching everything and saying
nothing.
One unusual interpretation of The Shining
is that it's less of an adaptation of Stephen
King's novel and actually a modern day retelling
of the ancient Greek myth of Theseus and the
Minotaur.
Just like the labyrinth that houses the Minotaur
in the myth, the Overlook has its hedge maze
where the movie hits its climax.
As Jack chases him, Danny escapes the maze
by retracing his steps, just as Theseus escapes
the labyrinth by following back a ball of
twine that he'd been unwinding as he walked.
Could this be a second meaning to the sign
outside the Gold Room that advertises "the
Unwinding Hours"?
At several points in the film, Jack stares
into the distance with a lowered head, but
with eyes pointed up, in the classic "Kubrick
stare," a pose that's very evocative of a
bull getting ready to charge.
Some theorists even cite the "Monarch" poster
in the game room, which again is for a real-life
ski resort you can go to, because the skier
is a silhouette with strange proportions.
It's a stretch, but the mythical Minotaur
was the descendant of a royal bloodline, which
leads to another oddly convincing connection.
In the original story, the Minotaur was the
product of a union between a human and a beast,
and, well, the audience and Wendy definitely
see something along those disturbing lines.
Something is up with this movie and mirrors.
Danny's first vision occurs in front of a
mirror.
Jack recognizes the woman he's kissing in
Room 237 is a corpse by looking into a mirror.
There's a long scene of Jack talking to Wendy
that takes place entirely in a reflection.
Danny's creepy "redrum" graffiti can only
be read correctly when mirrored.
The Grady girls are mirror images of each
other.
The film even opens with a shot of a reflective
lake, mirroring the scenery above it.
Perhaps the Overlook itself is a mirror, in
that it's only torturing guests with the evil
that they bring with them.
That would explain why Jack, an alcoholic
with a history of abusing his son, was corrupted
by the hotel, while Danny and Wendy were not.
Whether it's the true meaning of the movie
or not, the use of mirrors is definitely an
intentional illustration of one of The Shining's
deeper themes.
The idea of finding truth through looking
backwards through history or looking into
mirrors occurs all throughout the movie, from
the reveal of "redrum" as a terrifying warning
to Danny escaping his father in the hedge
maze by retracing his steps.
By looking backwards, Danny avoids becoming
a victim like the Grady children.
This idea of finding truth by turning backwards
has led to some fans to try playing two projections
of The Shining on the same screen at the same
time, one playing forwards and one playing
backwards to see if this finally reveals the
movie's many secrets.
It might not have led to any deeper truths,
but it has created some awesomely creepy imagery.
Then again, maybe this movie is the real mirror,
and these fan theories say more about us than
they do about the film.
Not all Shining theories are deadly serious
or profoundly deep, and some of them are so
wild that they're worth talking about for
just how weird they are.
For example, writer and journalist Mary Katharine
Ham has a theory that the story of the Shining
has been retold more recently…as Disney's
Frozen.
Before the story begins, our tortured protagonist
has a dark chapter in their past that looms
over their present, where they inadvertently
injured an innocent young family member.
Then, that volatile character is put in charge
of running a big castle in the snowy mountains.
Meanwhile, their innocent young family member
is locked out of a forbidden room, and passes
the time by playing with toys in the hallway,
and when things go bad, a wide-eyed, cheerful
character with prominent teeth tries to protect
them.
Eventually, the pressure of this new job causes
our dark and tortured protagonist to snap
and turn against their family.
The family is in over their heads, so it's
up to an experienced expert at navigating
the snowy wastes to climb aboard their faithful
mount to come to their rescue.
In the end, both movies end with a character
getting frozen.
In one case, it's temporary, and in another,
it's permanent, but you have to admit that
while everything might not line up, there's
enough there to have some goofy fun with.
It's a weird, ridiculous, and truly wild "theory,"
but for some reason we just can't…let it
go.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.